oh yeah that that that's a mustache
which could only mean one thing good
morning Hank it's Monday it's pus I
don't really know how to change up the
vibe from our community lowers the price
of life-saving tuberculosis tests to
pizz Miss where we make videos back and
forth every day like it was 2007 all
over again while celebrating the 7
Minutes in 2008 when I had a mustache
but we're doing it but of course pizz
Miss isn't just about my occasional
mustache and constant love for pizza
it's also about e-commerce and inside of
this box is all of this year's Pizza
Miss magic which I have not seen yet so
every year all of our proceeds go to
charity because you know of course we
can't live with ourselves profiting from
pizzas but this year the money raise is
going to be focused around tuberculosis
we've done a great job of lowering the
cost of Diagnostics and treatments but
now we need to get those Diagnostics and
treatments to more people so that's what
we're raising money for this year we're
going to start with the
T-shirt I love it so much so this is a
pizza John collab with dry and I love it
look at that it's so great okay what's
next I mean I just absolutely love this
I love my face in it look at my
enthusiasm for pizza it's so
real yes yes
yes yes I just love the T-shirt so much
every year how how did this happen how
did pizza Miss occur what what is my
life it's my dream Hank it's my dream to
one day be not just a postage stamp but
a pizza John postage stamp all right I
only have a couple more shirts to share
with you this year look at this one oh
magnificent look at me oh I should add
that all of these shirts and indeed all
of the pizza stuff is only available
during pizzamas you can only get it for
the next two weeks and then it
disappears forever pizz miss.com or our
new pizzamas app on your local app store
all right this is the
last those the last shirt of the year
and look at me up in the corner as a
baby but I still got a
mustache oh boy I um I don't know what
to say about this development except to
say that it's it's a it's a major work
of art but of course Hank it doesn't and
can't end with t-shirts oh no no no no
it has to include a phenomenal Pizza
John holiday sweater oh yeah I mean look
at this this is just excellent you may
remember that a few years ago we made
this pizza John blanket which is super
comfortable and I love it so much but
this one is also super comfortable and I
think I love it even more you have to be
me it's chees a John A John
that grows its own hair in the form of
plants this one you can only buy in the
United States because it has
seeds all right this is one I'm really
excited about it's Pizza John's hot
sauce now I'm not legally allowed to
sell the hot sauce that I make with my
mom cuz it's not made in a commercial
kitchen but this tastes pretty much like
it this is also only available in the
United States cuz it's like technically
food or whatever but highly recommended
oh we've got a mug printed in Missoula
that changes color when you pour hot
liquid into it I'm not telling you what
color it change I'm not going to ruin
the surprise this is a pizza John bath
bomb fortunately it does not smell like
pizza but do you know what does smell
like like so much like Dr Pepper leave
the dream turn your bath into Dr Pepper
pizz miss.com we've also got this badass
oven mitt you have to be kidding me this
cannot be real it's a real neon sign
that's right Hank it's a fully
functioning Pizza John's neon sign we've
also got lots of different stickers and
bumper stickers this year from the
Charming and funny to the exceptionally
creepy there's also so much other Pizza
Miss stuff this year a pizza slicer
earrings there's a stereogram poster one
of those posters where when you unfocus
your eyes a new image appears you'll
never guess what the image is actually
you will guess on the first try Hank
nerd Feria what a joy it has been to go
through my eras with you Hank I'll see
you tomorrow for more pizzas and
potentially for your first ever mustache
like I I think we're all curious which
way it's going to go we know something's
going to happen with the facial hair
tomorrow but everybody is waiting with
baited breath to find out exactly what